al pan
[Música]
una convocación masiva es lo que pidió
el presidente ya er bolsonaro él cree
que los ministros de la suprema corte de
brasil están limitando la libertad de
expresión al arrastrar a unos blogueros
de su base de apoyo para el cruzado una
línea importante mientras tanto los
jueces dicen que están cumpliendo la
constitución ya en los apoyadores
bolsonaro dicen que no hay más libertad
es la expresión están acá en las
planadas ministerios pidiendo que se
cumpla la constitución o sea o por lo
menos lo que entienden que es la
constitución hemos visto muchos carteles
de
anticomunistas pidiendo que tenga más
libertad para gobernar bolsonaro esos
son todos consignas que escuchamos
alrededor de lo que es el centro de
brasil a la explanada de los ministerios
aquí nosotros estamos acá para defender
los derechos fundamentales del ser
humano de la libertad de expresión es
nosotros buscamos libertad en nuestro
país no queremos ser gobernados por la
suprema corte no votamos a ministros
corte votamos por nuestro presidente
queremos el derecho de ser gobernados
por él
para la suprema corte decimos 'basta'
allá adentro hay una facción comunista
añadida al congreso nacional y apoyada
por el primer ministro como está chino
eso está pasando demuestra que podríamos
estar escribiendo una nueva historia
nuestro presidente es integralmente
demócrata republicano y respeta nuestra
libertad
ahora el presidente brasil y su
convocatoria para que millares de
brasileros salieran a la calle acá en
brasil acá estuvieran el hablo que es el
último alarme o sea la última vez que
llama la atención a los otros poderes
expresando un poco más las líneas
democráticas y él es pesos y contrapesos
mientras algunos apoyadores pierden la
intervención en el a la suprema corte de
brasil y también en el congreso no son
todos pero este brasileño dice que es el
último alerta quiere más poder para
asumir en otro mandato para por lo menos
intentarlo en 2022